[Musik]
und in 21 darf in der halo herzlich
willkommen so salis wir sind gerade mit
der ganzen familie on tour wir haben
nämlich gerade noch die osterferien und
die tage nutzen wird aus um mit der
familie ein bisschen urlaub zu machen
letztes jahr hat sie ihre ersten
milchzähne verloren und die zahnfee hat
ihr versprochen dass er in den
freizeitpark gehen darf und deswegen
sind wir jetzt hier
meine schwester wohnt in aachen also an
der niederländischen grenze und jetzt
immer hier in efteling und verbringen
hier wirklich richtig schöne tage
wir sind zum ersten mal hier aber meine
zuschauer haben schon gesagt dass es
hier richtig toll sein soll und vor
allem gibt es eine tolle märchenwelt ich
habe schon vieles gehört und jetzt
überzeugen wir uns selbst davon wer mit
sie auch schon unseren umschlag bekommen
mit unseren zimmer karten und gehe jetzt
einfach mal in unser kleines häuschen
concept x nein ich bin die erste sein
wie heißt die erste kammer mit gleich
eine toilette ist schnuckelig
[Musik]
sogar garten gehen raus und mein
spielplatz kaum ein spielplatz nicht so
stimmt wow dachte ich das hier schon da
sogar eine golfanlage kauf nicht dass
wir könnten auf 8 wir können gott
richtig schatz ich glaube abends dazu
wir sind jetzt ein paar tage hier
dann können wir tagsüber den markt
besichtigen und abends hier ein bisschen
entspannen
also wir richten uns mal ein murat guckt
schon nach den kids hier draußen und ich
guck mal mit meinen zuschauern das haus
an
[Musik]
hier drinnen sieht es wirklich super
schnuckelig aus also wirklich eine ganz
tolle wohnung oder ein kleines häuschen
die haben wir den esstisch die küche man
kann sich auf gefrühstückt zum beispiel
herr bestellen oder auch trügen park
frühstücken ja mal ein kleines
wohnzimmer man sich abends von ausruhen
sehr schön auch eine toilette ist hier
unten gucken wir mal oben nach den
schlafräumen
ach gott wie schön sie haben ein
badezimmer mit badewanne toilette und
waschbecken alles was man braucht hier
neben dem badezimmer haben wir
wahrscheinlich unser schlafzimmer da
werden wir schlafen hier noch ein
bettchen für die ella wenn sie das
schlafen will
ansonsten haben wir hier nebendran noch
ein zimmer ich habe mir noch mal ein
großes schlafzimmer ich denke dass meine
beiden mädels hier schlafen werden und
im nebenraum ich hatte drei schon jetzt
regnet nämlich draußen
wir sind hier im kinderzimmer ja mal
gucken was die hier anstellen ich habe
mir nämlich ein hochbett für zwei kinder
ein hochbett gewünscht morath es steht
dir hier und da ist das spiel
ich glaube fühlt euch wohl oder die drei
können sie noch ein bisschen austoben
ich pack mal kurz und so sachen aus wird
sie uns dann an und geh nach draußen
[Musik]
unser erster stopp ist hier vor dem
königlichen palast des königs adolphus
und zwar hat er uns eingeladen und wir
werden hier zu suchen
kannst du mir da
zanella sind schon vor
[Musik]
wir zitieren der symbolik dem
königlichen palast von verdruss
hier gibt's die musik helden und die
schatztruhe und jede tour ist ein
bisschen anders am ende vereinen sie
sich aber im ballsaal ein festmahl
natürlich hat dann der volle für uns die
pfannkuchen bereich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tor um tor auf
[Musik]
farfus
august haben wir ja schon
[Musik]
wenn ich gewusst dass er fotografiert
werden hätten vielleicht caches
samira kunst bett lag
[Musik]
also hier gibt diesen ofen und da spielt
er alle 20 minuten verrückt da können
die gäste hier sitzen und pfannkuchen
essen pfannkuchen sind eine spezialität
jetzt ganz verschiedene verschiedene
rezepturen und ich glaube dass eine
schöne idee ist dass du das ist ein ganz
gut
also der faule tabak hier die
pfannkuchen für das maskottchen pathos
und natürlich auch für den könig und
bitte von gleis pfannkuchen probiert und
werden auch selber in der kirche ein
paar punkerin vorbereiten muss für die
wasserpumpe suchen den wasser punkt zu
ihrer auch und dann kommt eine
jubeltraube wasser trinken jetzt merke
man dass man versuchen muss der wasser
punkt zumal ist sauber wasser dankeschön
wir gehen auf die suche kommt mit
[Musik]
oh oh oh ist es sauber wasser wir haben
das saubere wasser gefunden welche farbe
ist dass ella
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist es leckeres sauber wasser gibt's
immer verzaubert in können die kranken
probieren
[Musik]
sagen wir mal der ellar im pankower in
spray hätte ich auch meistens mitbringen
kann ja
[Musik]
sehr schön
tolles pankofen teiglinge zeige ich das
mal wieder zu hause sind und da müssen
jetzt abholen so gut waren okay so sieht
man die verschiedenen toppings hier
schon die herzhaften da sind auch noch
äpfel dabei und man kann da mit seinem
pfannkuchen nach wunsch bestellen lehrer
und eltern möchten natürlich sie es mit
schokolade
jonas
jetzt belegen wir eben zusammen
[Musik]
klar hat er den flug gefressen ja sag
mal was wie nokia frei macht den mund
auf ich glaube da frisst uns schnell
kommen wir rennen weg haben wir doch mal
rein
darin hat der pinocchio ihn zum leben
erweckt guck mal die tanzen ja alle und
holte die haben ein konzert wie tanzen
mit kürze die balancieren auf dem seil
es ist schön elan
[Musik]
hallo rotkäppchen
und überall sind hier diese
musikalischen pilze verteilt komm mal
richtig schön gelb
[Musik]
marcumar patrick märchen
halla jeder prinz der um die hand der
schönen prinzessin anhieb bekam von der
bösen königin schwierige aufgaben
gestellt die armen prinzen verloren
immer ihren kopf als liter ein prinz zu
dem schluss kam dass an ihm die königin
drei mögliche aufgaben
sie hatte dabei aber nicht mit seinen
sechs zählern gerechnet so spitz krisen
schnell fuß wrestling kugel auge und
langhals dank ihrer besonderen talente
waren die aufgaben hin zu spielen da ist
lang als termin 4,8 meter langen hals
und die attraktion war eine der ersten
attraktionen tm baden habe
[Musik]
hier ist mal rein
ich glaube wir sind glückspilze das gold
aus getroffen hat gold sieben silber
hoppala
hier ist übrigens der ort und dem rat
und nicht kennengelernt haben früher
waren hier nämlich fünf frösche dann bin
ich hin
habt ihr einen gekürzt und die eine
größe das oder murat
[Musik]
vor 66 jahren hat der park genau hier
angefangen nämlich mit dem märchenwald
hinter mir seht ihr gerade des kaisers
neue kleider kowitz kannst du mit tanzen
oder kaiser
ich glaube der kaiser karin vertragen
das ganz sagt
[Musik]
der kaiser ist nackt beim sprechenden
märchen raum und der ist so wunderschön
gemacht also wie aus dem märchen viel
wahnsinn und er lacht ich glaube die
weiß kann man so sagen soll
[Musik]
als die mutter rein fliegen im tram flog
wie wir schon mal vor ich holen uns noch
was
ja wir wollten gerade im traum das war
wirklich wunderschön regt die fantasie
der kinder an
hier gibt es jetzt eine kleine snack bar
und zwar gibt es jeden tag natürlich
auch ganz viele snacks wie pommes und so
weiter kompletten alles mögliche hier
gibt es aber auch eine gesunde ecke hier
gibt's frische smoothies obst gemüse man
kann sich einen joghurt holen
man kann auch gesunde andere snacks
haben oder obst im ganzen
das finde ich wirklich schön so kann man
sich den ganzen tag wirklich auch
einfach mal gesund ernähren
jetzt wenn wir beide eigenheim ort
ergibt nämlich die leckeren spiral
kartoffeln und ihre hat die sich
gewünscht
weil wir mal
[Musik]
sehr lecker
hätte doch bloß in der menschenwelt
geblieben nicht gleich mit den baron um
mein gott oh nein der bleibt bestehen
oh mein gott
alle bleiben hier nicht mehr alleine
rein das nicht ich werde das nicht
machen dann wenn mir was passiert sind
wir alle kaputt wir jetzt weiter gut
geht johlt neubauer das guthaben auch
etwas gehe jetzt rein
[Musik]
den fahrstuhl hier finde ich total
faszinierend sind so können auch
gehbehinderte menschen einfach mit dem
baron fahren da kommt man mit dem
rollstuhl drauf wird nach oben gefahren
und kann sich dann auch einsetzen falls
sich danach nicht mehr dazu kommen
sollte
der baron ist eine sehr geldgieriger
mensch und insekt zu dem abgrund ganz
viel goldes natürlich geht man da nicht
alleine rein sondern schickt einfach da
rein und dem abgrund im weißen frauen
die versuchen alle die die mine betreten
also komme ich dann wahrscheinlich
gleich versucht hier wieder raus und
mein gott
[Musik]
es geht los
am ganzen körper
vielen freiberuflichen um einen mitte
[Musik]
neben einer sanften bevor
das sagen wir machen
[Musik]
besonders auf
was sagen ich liebe euch alle danke für
alles was wir bisher zusammen erlebt
haben
oh mein gott
ich weiß nicht warum ich mir das antue
mir steht und mit dem
hilfe
keine bank gefunden
warum
der müll ein schweres stück gut ab
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei tausendundeiner
macht jetzt gehen wir mal in die
orientalische welt
[Musik]
wow
mit dem boot fahren das ist schön
da gehen wir gleich mal rein
[Musik]
wenn eine million
haben
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir noch festen boden unter
den füßen aber jetzt geht's 45 meter in
die höhe und zwar auf einem karussell
und dann drehen wir uns oben einmal
komplett
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir hinter uns in die
holzachterbahn danach soll er auch mit
rein jahresertrag also lloris und der
drache das ist eine duellieren der
achterbahn das heißt man entscheidet
sich am anfang für feuer oder wasser und
der gewinner wird am ende dann bejubelt
unter anderem mit ausgebaut
ich hoffe entscheidend jetzt richtig und
konnte dafür natürlich gewinnen mit
neben dran bist du schon über 120 81 14
da müssen wir schon 128 deswegen hast ja
die kleidergröße kommen wir gehen rein
ich weiß ihr papa groß genug jetzt aber
wo hat ständig auch mal den himmel
[Musik]
ich hab nur eine gewinnen
die vorher seite
jetzt eine kamera die keine großen
klassen
[Musik]
januar
[Gelächter]
bis morgen auftauchen
[Musik]
wir beenden unsere wunderschönen tag
heute hier bei der wassershow bei aqua
nova das ist die drittgrösste fontänen
show weltweit also zuerst kommen las
vegas und dubai und dann efteling sie
schon geht etwa eine viertelstunde und
jetzt lassen jetzt hier nochmal
faszinieren
[Musik]
gibt es kein feuer
[Applaus]
gut mal gerne morgen wir haben gut
geschlafen und jetzt gehts weiter hier
im park
[Musik]
aber gibt es frisches brot kommen wir
mit die machen gerade den teig und
backen wir uns ein brot er als kind
einmal die backen über hd rolle
lecker und die sind so fleißig dass die
erdbeertorte
ich habe aber gehört hier gibt es auch
im brauhaus und das suchen wir jetzt mal
komm mal mitkommen rutsche
kommen wir nehmen die drohung mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber dicker dürft ihr auch nicht sein
[Musik]
das ist endlich auch mal ein gebäude wo
sich der murat wohlfühlt weil die decken
einfach nicht so hoch sind da schon drin
stehen das hereingekommen kommen gehen
weiter
[Musik]
los geht's mir wird nicht schlecht man
wird nicht schlecht mir wirklich
schlecht
ok ich muss sagen achterbahn ist was für
mich aber kettenkarussell nicht da wird
mir ganz schlecht schnell weiter
[Musik]
wieso müssen wir hier ganz vorne so
zimmer
bis 10
[Musik]
so ein mist
fest sehen mal wie war es fertig ich
kann jetzt ich brauche jetzt
mittagsschlaf oder sein spiel platz kam
guck mal da sind piano com
[Musik]
nochmal noch mal
ich schaue die falschen tonlage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer jetzt davon geschlichen papa und lfa
noch karussell und wir gehen jetzt
butter tier zu essen das ist auch eine
spezialität hier in den niederlanden und
zwar sind jetzt ganz kleine pancake
können wir mit das riecht schon so
lecker immer der nase nach
weil da drinnen deister eingang sieht
das lecker aus
hallo für euch gibt es leckere
profitiert na klar
erst meine hände sind eine schürze hand
sondern markiert
es ist pause
jetzt finden wir hier erst mal das eisen
mit teeröl dann braucht doch nicht so
pancakes zeigt darin seht ihr schon man
muss die nicht einzeln für 12 sekunden
82 sekunden lassen und umgekehrt
[Musik]
eine mitarbeiterin des monats zurückgibt
immer viel zu sehen
und dann hier abstellen
dollar
[Musik]
komm ich probiere auch direkt hier
murat beschäftigt gerade kind ist für
mich eine kleine pause drin ist ein
echter schokolade
also ausließen teig ihnen gefüllt mit
sahne und dann mit kuvertüre über suchen
kaum mit süß kommt dieser mir also
schmeckt lesungen riesen windbeutel
gefüllt mit sahne und dann überzogen mit
couture
uns hat der aufenthalt in efteling
wirklich super gut gefallen
und wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr
jetzt beim gewinnspiel mitmachen zu
gewinnen gibt es zwei tage übernachtung
in efteling für eine vierköpfige familie
und zum mitmachen könnt ihr einfach
einen kommentar hinterlassen unter
diesem video
schreibt mir einfach was euch an diesem
video am besten gefallen hat was euch
ein echter ding faszinieren würde und
schreibt einfach dazu ich möchte
gewinnen
der gewinner wird per los gezogen und
ich mach dazu dann ein posting nächste
woche
[Musik]
für uns ist unsere tour in erster linie
zu leider schon zu ende wir hatten hier
wirklich drei wunderschöne tage also für
uns als fazit gilt es ist wirklich für
alle kinder geeignet von klein bis groß
sowohl hatte ihren spaß als auch samira
und natürlich ist ein bisschen karussell
gefahren er hat auch seinen spaß was ich
auf jeden fall als tipp mitgeben kann
neben gleich einen bollerwagen oder
kinderwagen mit und wenn ihr keinen habt
dann können wir hier natürlich auch was
ausleihen so dass die kinder einfach
nicht so lange laufen müssen uns ganz
besonders dass der park in einem
naturpark ist man hat wirklich ganz viel
natur um sich herum sieht auch ein paar
ganz tolle und süße tiere und ich würde
euch auf jeden fall empfehlen zwei bis
drei tage herzukommen am besten mit
übernachtung entweder könnt ihr euch im
hotel verwöhnen lassen oder so wie wir
ein kleines häuschen mieten mit
selbstversorgung ihr könnt natürlich
auch was zu essen mit in den park nehmen
oder hier die vielen kulinarischen
köstlichkeiten auch hier ausprobieren
also ich hoffe euch hat dieses video
gefallen lassen wir auf jeden fall mal
ein kommentar da wenn ihr schon mal hier
war oder wenn ihr den park mal besuchen
möchte es ist auf jeden fall den ausflug
wert bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
wittlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
juli
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
ok
[Musik]
letzter
[Gelächter]